every creative person should consider
themselves primarily responsible for the
success of their career is that true it
is an absolutely true statement that
every credit person needs to be that
primarily responsible person who
stewards their own career who's the
architect it's great if you have others
with their oars in the water helping you
it's great if you have an agent it's
great if you have a manager if you have
an attorney if you have other people who
are mentors or wear different hats in
your life who contribute strategy time
effort money whatever all those things
are all contributions smart and well
intended contributions are welcome of
course but the statement that we hear so
often from a creative if only I had an
agent is an unfortunate statement in my
view because even when you have one
you're still 100% responsible when I was
a personal manager representing
primarily writers and directors some
actors but when I was a literary manager
my attitude was first I had to deal with
my writer you work as hard at being
writers I work as being your
representative and we're going to get
along great but by the way you're still
100% responsible for your career and by
the way so am i I'm a hundred percent
responsible for your career and when we
get you an agent
the agents 100 percent responsible for
your career now we got three hundred
percent
sounds like the producers but it's true
I could never allow anyone to be even 1%
responsible or I wasn't doing much
giving my all so when they get an agent
when they get a manager when they get
people who want to jump on board that's
great but it's frosting it's not the
cake they have to be the one because you
know what at the end of the day it's
their personality it's their talent it's
their signature in the world that is
going to win the day an agent can only
open a door make an introduction set the
table but the writer or the actor or
whomever has to walk into the room
literally and metaphorically and win the
day it has to be their vision it has to
be their voice and has to be their style
it has to be their personality and
energy that seduces the universe into
saying yeah I want to play with you your
dream is going to get moving it make a
you we're going we're going to make your
dream come true
because what you bring with you not
because your agent said X or your
manager did why that's not the truth the
truth is they just opened the door which
by the way you could have opened on your
own had you understood that you could
open it on your own but yeah the talent
can't just be the talent the talent has
to understand even if it's not about how
many hours a day they invest on the
business side of their life it's more
deeper it's deeper than that
that's an understanding that I'm going
to well this into being I'm going to
well people into my life who are going
to help me I'm going to will new
relationships into my life I'm going to
take action that pays dividends so if
you had a performer or writer what have
you in your chair and you're there sort
of slumped down and they're saying you
know this isn't working and I have this
agent a manager they're not sending me
out or they're not you know whatever
it's bei that they're putting the blame
one thing the other person what would
you say to them make them wrong show
them how it gets done you want to
complain about your agent your manager
not getting you auditions or whatever it
happens to be great show them how to
kick up some dust
you get yourself the audition it's not
okay to sit home and complain you know
the glass doesn't happen
do you ever ever ever ever you know
we're all well we're all allowed our
moment we're all allowed to have that
one day or that preferably that one hour
right then you have to dust yourself off
and say six
is about moving on with it and if other
people aren't getting it done for you
then then you've got to motivate them
and the best way to motivate someone is
to show them what they're not doing by
doing it yourself
you